let's start with the next session on
higher order optimization and as
promised we'll talk about acceleration
now uh Sim
so uh we saw AGD and I'll just write
down the algorithms just so that it's
easy to compare how these higher order
acceleration things have evolved
so AGD one way to write kgd as Alina
mentioned there are many many
interpretations and I'll write one
formulation for Accelerated gradient
descent and
let's see
so you start with at iteration t
so this was the gradient descent step so
for accelerating great innocent you do
one of this and
let's
do another step I'll Define another
variable and
this one goes over the
sum
[Music]
okay so this is more likely iterate we
saw in the morning uh but
So This Together along with so I have
defined Y Z now it's time to Define X
and let's say x
1 gives you
and we have these constants
okay so this is one uh approach to
accelerated gradient descent which this
is like the lower bound that we saw in
the morning and another interpretation
is this give if you just minimize this
this tries to give you a point that's
close to the optimizer
um in like the point is close to the
optimizer the distance is closed and
this one is the upper bound and an
interpretation is that this gives you uh
the function value close to the
optimizer so in a way you're trying to
do both your trying to it's trying to do
something that's a trade-off of you know
minimizing the function error and
minimizing the distance to the optimizer
so for first order we saw this and this
gave us uh
this gave us a rate that went on as 1
over
use T here so 1 over T Square
with iteration t
and
so for first order we had this the next
attempt on increasing going to higher
orders was
by nestorov and base in 2009 and 2019
perspective oh no first we actually had
something for second order which was
called accelerated cubic Newton in 2008
and then uh it slowly moved to higher
order the first attempt short by base
and then by nestro and they give a
similar algorithm and let's look at the
pH order version for this so remember
this we have upper bound we have
this thing that gives so we have
something that gives you a faster
function
error decrease distance increase and
interpolation so what nestorov did and
base did was a natural extension of this
you replace this
so let's say
this step becomes
so this is the Taylor approximation
plus the regularizer that we saw in the
previous lecture so the same thing
what do we have here
so this part Remains the Same the next
part actually they modify it a little
bit
to use the same function
yeah it's still two Norms everything is
euclidean yes
yes so now you have the same linear
combination of
is excise
but the regularization here is
minus X naught to the P plus 1. so they
started so they changed this to P plus 1
they change this to minimize the uh
upper Bound in this case
and
oh yeah sorry okay
and then the next one is uh
and then the same x t plus 1
was again
and these constants are again the same
but now you use the 1 by the pH
Lipschitz constant
also be good so the return value is
not there's no averaging like no no
there's no average and we're just
returning the last
right and it's the same over here yep
previously you gave us the gradient
different version like for you know for
uh
optimization
for that uh that's yeah I don't think we
know this version for that like okay
can I ask why you say the C of T it's
like
uh well I mean you know like if you look
at this step for example for the L2 5
for P equals one this is kind of 40
though the mirror descent when you're in
euclidean
it's like you're taking an average of
these subspaces and some regularization
most of the sum okay
okay
I guess also you said the analysis like
the function error of YT is considered
and the distance of ZT to opt is
considered yeah
but an algorithmic answer but like a
structure yeah yeah that's good okay
great so after doing this uh
unfortunately we don't get the optimal
rates and the rates that you get it
converges as something like
into these ones people do it
okay but now uh
if you want to see the optimal algorithm
and I'm going to change this point here
so that we can compare it to that so the
optimal algorithm actually for p equals
2 was given by Montero and schweiter in
2010 and that algorithm gave a rate of
convergence that was 1 by P to the 7 by
2 so the cubic accelerated cubic Newton
gave us something that's 1 by T cubed
and what these people gave was 1 by T to
the 7 by 2 which is you know slightly
better and this is
actually
Okay so
let's see what the optimal
opt higher order
so this was first given by Iron and
co-authors in
this paper that's near optimal
acceleration which is an extension of
the monteros fighter frame work to PS
orders yeah is that guy I forgot to call
it
yeah let me see if I remember the
quarters there were three groups groups
oh yes yes they all had these things oh
uh joint paper and culture so there's a
joint paper with a number
and it's only automatic factors yeah
so let's see what this happens looks
like
so the first change is
let me write this
so the first change is this is not a
constant anymore this depends on
something so it's changing
the next thing so this part
let me change
Taylor
okay so this part Still Remains the Same
as the non-optimal one and this one
just remains
so this does this is the same as the
first order one so now we're
regularization is basically still
squared instead of p plus one and they
click that comes now
is
so the first thing I'm going to do is
move this up here so XP is
[Music]
Magic
okay my first thing is you do this and
I'm also
going to be a little hand ready and say
that Lambda T so that's the thing I have
not defined yet is something like
white
okay yeah
[Applause]
oh my God
okay so I'm going to
so if we look at the algorithm we
basically
working with these ratios which is
changing with iterate and I want to say
that this Lambda is something like this
so if we first look at the algorithm you
see that y t plus 1 depends on x t
or before that x t depends on 80
and 80 and 80 plus 1 and these depend on
Lambda I Lambda I depends on y t y t
depends on you know x t so it's kind of
like a circular
algorithm and you may ask how do we but
suppose you knew what Lambda T was so if
you knew what Lambda T was this
algorithm is well defined and it's
straightforward but if you didn't know
what Lambda T was then it's like a
circular
uh
circular definition so the way to get
around this is you do a binary search
and we know how to do a binary search
and
value for Lambda T once you have this
then you run this algorithm
so for now we'll just assume we know
Lambda T so that makes a lot of these
things easier
okay so this algorithm is actually known
to uh
give a very good convergence rate so it
should go down as
1 by T to the
DP plus 1 over 2.
and this is known to be optimal
so this is all up to logs and
you can get this convergence rate
okay
[Music]
uh so I'm hoping that let's see at least
how do we prove this algorithm and this
is uh going to hopefully present a very
simplified version of this proof the
original proof is not so simple but Arun
here has
managed to give a very simplified proof
for this and I'll be presenting that so
let's look at that
specialized
yes which is the same as
but
is the
algorithm which seems to adapt the
weight
or various parameters based on the
sequence of
steps he doesn't make the analysis of
the standard
equal to the case more transparent
easier uh okay that's a good question so
the question is that does this for p
equals one make it much more
transparently sort of like yeah
I think for people so this is an
extension of Montero spider
with this algorithm by montero's white
one
acceleration which is slightly different
from atg in the standard setting and
that also has these implicit steps sizes
so I don't think it really gives a lot
of insight into EG D and D for p equals
one
still
nothing everything's exclusive oh yeah
yeah oh sorry yeah when people but
Montana's fighter is not quite explored
I think they're doing like approximately
and the version you described there
should not be an opinions
okay yeah
basically the point is
um when he is more than one
basically the point is when p is more
than one there's some slight
non-implicit list there's some
circularity in the step but in the
monteras fader paper and most follow-ups
you can sort of realize that by binary
searching over this you can
find you can input a value Lambda or
guess a value Lambda and then get out
this Lambda T and you can make them
match arbitrarily closely and only costs
like a log Factor
okay out of curiosity there is no hope
that it is like a fixed Point problem
that you can solve because it's a
contraction
is the first time that I see and then
which is equivalent to my language that
is a fixed Point problem
s
there's a type of answer your question I
think there are like General Frameworks
towards what's being discussed that I
think are rather a nice and clean
um but yeah the case when you're because
when you're doing acceleration this
thing of some sort of circular
dependence on this land that just
doesn't arise
so there's maybe a Clarity in seeing the
general framework but there's also
genuinely a complication that's used to
arise when you go beyond people's one
because at least that's my my intuition
you tell stories about that broader
story
okay
so okay so for approving this
um
the first thing we need which
call it Lemma
so let's define this potential function
which is just this 80 times
a function error
so the potential function is just
tracking how much you have gone down in
the function value and how close are you
to the optimum and what we can prove is
uh if we like this
so then basically if I take this one
okay
so the first thing we need is
um if you just look at this potential
function this is decreasing at something
that depends on Lambda and depends on
this
and uh
if you assume this first let's see if
you assume this then how do you get the
rate that we are looking for and uh see
that
so we will still think of you know
Lambda T to be just
so just assume this
and
so okay so if you look at this a t this
a t is basically an increasing function
these a all these A's are positive and
it's all true so you can look at this
partition so let's start at a 0
A1
so this is let's say the number line you
have some a t
to the final iterate
and if you just look at this in the end
you want uh
so in the end you basically want 80 to
be something that's like five zero by
Salon also
uh this is just because if we do some
suppose you can do some induction here
and Phi t plus 1 is at most let's say if
I I mean you can do an induction ignore
this 5T in the end is at most Pi zero
and uh you want this function you get
this 80 from here so so you just want to
look at 80 until this point and let me
just look at some point
and divide this into phases so these
iterations let's say uh
these iterations are such that
these is are less than some 2 to the I
so let's just look at one of these faces
and see how many iterations can you
actually have in each phase and
so if so if so for this way so we're
just looking at the it rates oh sorry
Edition let me call this new
so we're just looking at iterate so that
this capital A is just between these and
for such iterates we can let me classify
this into
um two times so let's say T1
is the
okay one more thing is I'm going to call
this as r
so I'll just call this difference
so I'm going to classify this into two
parts so one is the total number of
iterates such that this RT plus 1 is
less than some threshold R which I'll
choose later
and T2 is
is greater than r and we'll just see how
many of each can you have
so uh
let's start by bounding P2
so if you want to
on T2 let's look at this potential again
and
what we know is that Pi t plus 1
foreign
so just from this potential decrease
argument you just get this and now let's
say our t plus 1 is at least r
so you can get this
and we basically don't want this to be
we basically have that this is at least
zero
and if you want to bound the number of
such possible steps you can
you would basically get that Tito
at most
[Music]
0 by
say I
oh before that let's also see we also
know that these A's are in this range
so I'm going to replace this by
Filipino
and then you can just say that this is
at most
so this is the maximum number of steps
you can have of this kind
and then to look at this uh
um I'm going to use this fact that's
proven in most of these acceleration
things that
basically says
so once you're given this fact uh
and you're given this bone this
basically means you have a
so this is just using that
lamp RT plus one is greater than r or
sorry is at most r
and this would just give us something
that
we won by
you can have at most these many of
such things
and we also know that so you can
basically say that
so this is at most uh
and this
so let's
is at most two to the
again because we're in this one phase
so from this
and this we have the total number of
iterations in each phase uh
I want to balance out
these values so you have that the total
iterates in let's say phase new
is rebounded by some
by 0 by
uh let's see
okay
so I want to balancing these out you can
actually set R to be
something that
something that's of this sort so if you
balancing these you can set R to be this
and
once we put it back into the total time
uh you basically get that this
is some
to to the new times 2 by
2 plus 1.
so this is for phase new you can by
splitting these two kinds of
uh
iterates you can basically show that you
get something that the total iterates
are some to the new raised to some 2 by
3 p plus 1. and now we
so the total so we want to sum it over
All Phases and the total time
is number of
places and this is also an increasing
function because two to the Nu keeps
increasing we're increasing new so this
times
Max
value of
and
so this is something like log n a log 1
by
Epsilon let's say
and the maximum value of new that you
want is Phi 0 by Epsilon
and that gives you something that's
go by Epsilon to the
2 by 3 p plus one so this gives us the
uh rate on Epsilon and if we look back
it's
matches this so if you want this to be
less than
Epsilon we
the number of steps you need is
proportional to f 1 by Epsilon to the
two by three p plus one
okay
so what we showed so far is if you
assume this then you get the right
convergence rate
now are there any questions
so now this is the main place where we
actually need all of the modifications
that we saw from the uh originally
proposed AGD
and I'm going to cheat a little bit more
in trying to
prove this
and
so I'm going to cheat a little more and
I'm going to say that uh
instead of y t plus 1 minimizing this
uh going to cheat and make y t plus 1
minimize
this instead and
you can actually believe that you can
implement this using
um a few number of the original
minimization problem that you have but
going to cheat and I'm going to say that
let's just have wife
p plus one minimize this
so uh let's look at two things
what does this y t plus 1 mean I mean
what
let's characterize this and this next
so I'll just use the optimality
conditions for both
and what you get is
so
let's go here
so we can say that gradient F of y t
plus 1
oh sorry I also forgot that I want to
blender tea and square
yes hi so I'm going to cheat and
solve this so since our Lambda T was
basically YT plus 1 minus x t
it's almost the same problem
so
um optimality this is the
this is just by differentiating this and
setting it to 0 we get this
and if we and we saw it this morning
that if you just minimize these then you
actually get
ah
oh sorry I forgot one more thing
this algorithm it's not on X we're going
to change it to be using these wise
and this should just be
okay
so we have these characters so this is
uh what we know about date rates YT plus
1 and z t plus one and
now let's
[Music]
prove our original thing
so I'm going to split it into two parts
the first one
says that
[Music]
because I'm going to look at this term
I'm going to
lower bound this by
I'm going to save this and also going to
give an upper bound on this
or rather
[Music]
but rather I can give an equality that
this is
okay so given these two uh you can see
that this directly follows
uh your 5T is just this Plus this term
and this is at T and at t plus 1 and you
exactly get that back
[Music]
and to prove this
uh this one is much easier
so so this one actually just uses
convexity and this one uses uh these
because in some way it just uses the
cosine law and an easy way to see this
is
you can just I can replace this so from
optimality
you have this
and this is just Z T minus e t plus one
so this is just equal to
once you have this inner product you can
use the cosine law which is basically
that if you have
I mean this is then exactly equal to
this with so this is exactly equal to
and this is easy to verify if you just
expand these
and once you have this then we again
so then we do two things we replace ZT
minus ZT plus one
first using this Lemma
so this just becomes
80 plus 1 squared
and then you can use
this first point to replace this
gradient with
Lambda t squared and
and from the way we choose these
coefficient which was here
sorry
ah sorry so many typos yeah but
so from that this just becomes 80 plus
one
I mean this constant changes to this
so this part was easy to see
and for this we just want to use that
the function f is convex and we can do
some splitting and actually just
this directly follows that's an easy
exercise you can see
or this one
Ah that's gold
I mean we're using
so this is where we're cheating
to get this
correct so if you combine just use some
connection you get that and this is just
you can combine it and this gives you
this potential with this all right
yeah so this is a much easier proof
thanks to Arun and the original one had
a
bunch of more intricate things and we're
still ignoring the fact how to do the
line search and that here
changing this tool
an easier problem
so yeah
so this is what I
wanted to present today
I'm happy to take questions
thank you questions
yep so you you mentioned us them up so
you mentioned some applications to
discrete optimization for these higher
order methods uh good uh or discrete as
in these ckmst kind of yeah
okay right so
so this is uh a higher order extension
of this Montero sweater acceleration
framework there's a work the easiest way
to achieve this is you can use this kind
of acceleration in this Oracle in this
new kind of Oracle model which was
defined if so which is in this paper
called acceleration via ball Oracle
um
yeah acceleration via ball Oracle and
this ball Oracle and that's Again by uh
iron Aaron Kevin yojia
um
so in that they basically use this
Oracle where you are allowed so you're
given as let's say in a small euclidean
ball you can exactly minimize the
function and given this uh standard a
naive gradient descent kind of approach
or rather approach where you just move
to the new minimizer of the
um
or I mean of the function inside like
you keep Shifting the ball uh like that
that kind of gives you a rate that's the
initial total distance divided by the
radius of the ball so to convert and
time some log on by Epsilon so you can
use this kind of acceleration to speed
it up to let's say uh so you had
something like
uh the initial distance say d by the
radius of the ball are you can speed it
up to D by R to the two thirds using
this kind of acceleration and once you
do that you can
there are direct applications
for soft Max and these integration
problems and the way to see that is so
you can Implement these ball oracles
very easily for these soft mugs and some
regression kind of problems because soft
Max
has this property of Hessian stability
and with that I mean that the second
order derivative does not change a lot
outside a small range so in this ball
basically for soft marks the Hessian is
kind of since it's off by let's say a
constant factor and because of that you
can Implement these ball oracles very
efficiently and once you have the soft
Max so you can think so once you have
soft Max that means you directly have
something for Infinity regression and
that means you directly have something
for Max flow and the rate that you
actually get is so I said you have this
D by R to the two thirds and so you can
think of the initial distance as
something like m to the one half if the
size is M so once you can go from m to
the one half to m to the one third in
this particular way wow I guess that's
very schedule but I can talk more
offline or you can ask our own
any more questions
[Music]
both of them would be high level but
um and also it could be like related
also to the first order the first one is
like in the equation of City
uh Alpha T is like preconditioning like
it's changing together it is Multiplied
with the gradient is there a version
that it is post conditioning I I don't
request necessarily but out of curiosity
like is it even that detail super
important to have a acceleration like
having Alpha T outside of the Sun this
is one question this is one question
that I have and the other question is
like
very nice like accelerate descent is a
thing that always takes time to
understand the proof I have an a
question like in non-euclidean spaces
like manifolds there are like very in
esoteric I would call them at least
papers that they say ah look there are
some lower bounds that you cannot do
acceleration I try to follow a lot the
proof Can you spot out like ah here is
the moment that we used a lot the
euclideanity of the space okay so for
the first question uh these AIS being
different is actually uh like in the
morning session Alina explained you're
kind of looking at hyper planes and
you're looking at different hyper planes
that you know are below the function
because it's convex you have these
hyperplanes so when you look at these
different hyper planes eventually you
don't want to give the same weight to
every hyperplane because some of them
are more important and some are not so
these being different is kind of helping
you get a better hyperplane that you
know is below the function and the
second one I mean we're taking these
optimality conditions and these
derivatives so that's very euclidean
please like the last dilemma that you
present yeah like this one is
but I think you can ex I think you can
extend these to non-euclidean Norms am I
right uh maybe Arun has a better answer
to that but maybe you can extend these
to non-euclidean Norms but beyond that
I'm not sure
um
yeah
any other questions
all right let's make sure again
um so that's it for the program today uh
I was asked to make an announcement from
one of the the social organizers I
believe there's music night or a music
event going on it should be advertised
on the Zulu so you can check it check it
out there so that's happening this
evening
um and we'll be back tomorrow morning
with the program with coffee at nine and
talk at 9 30 for our last uh day of this
boot camp and friendly reminder that
tomorrow at 11 A.M is when we'll have
the town hall towards us organ deciding
how we want to organize things for the
rest of the program so
think about that feel free to come find
me and chat and I'll look forward to
seeing you all later thanks
[Applause]